listen to how the ladies at the view and
I always have to apologize to my
audience before we play a clip from The
View but here we go listen to how the
ladies of the view are describing what
DeSantis is doing this week
you know Rhonda Sanchez went to Harvard
and and Yale yes he did so he's got a
very good education now he doesn't want
anybody else to have it you know
and that's famous right I mean I took it
seriously when Donald Trump said I love
the undereducated the pulley the poorly
educated he said that specifically and I
think that Ron DeSantis is taking you
know that page out of that Playbook
because the less people know
the easier it is for those people to to
sort of Gaslight them and and snooker
them and I think what's so offensive to
me and what you kind of just alluded to
it is that he only targeted
African-American AP students yes that's
right everything else was fair game you
can learn about Latinos you could learn
about Japanese you could learn about
Asia and everybody but not black folks
which are the very Foundation of this
country well those are the ones but
that's the black the black community in
this country has suffered from slavery
that's why we built this country for
free he doesn't I know that are you tell
him I mean he doesn't want people to
know that because they don't make white
people feel bad and we want our
reparations for it this is soil Sharpton
there I think that these people these
fascists out there like DeSantis they
think that we're just going to sit back
and let them do whatever they want no
we're not we've been we've seen this
movie before okay those of us who lived
in the 60s and 70s we saw this movie
there was many there were many many
fashions tactics coming down the pike
from Nixon and the rest of these
fascists that's what they are and and we
protested and we protested and we ended
a war that was illegal and we we did
stuff and it's happening again that's
the goodness it's not happening it's not
happening enough in Florida
first though wait I've said it many
times but I'm told that I live about
five minutes away from Anna Navarro and
I just cannot wait to meet this woman
somewhere why is she living in this
fascist State why doesn't she leave I
have no idea but Heather it's like what
the high hell is Joy talking about what
fascist takeover is Ron DeSantis doing
what war does Ron DeSantis want us to go
to all he's doing is pushing back it
really is that simple
I I guess Bahar is like in some time
warp she doesn't look like it but she
seems to be maybe still a 14 year old
her level of of intellectual
sophistication is is you know that low
and these were the people who were
complaining at the beginning of of
DeSantis not wanting people to be
educated right right I mean the the lack
of knowledge of what fascism actually
means this is just absolute knee-jerk
smear now I'm I'm always asking myself
Dave
they would say the same about us you
know let's just be honest they would say
that we are just as knee-jerk in our use
of blanket epithets uh and so I I always
sort of probe like do we do the same
thing in calling them I don't know I
mean we call them totalitarianism they
they do want to shut down speech
one one could debate that I mean one
would need evidence on both sides sure
let's just say in this case though uh
it's it's completely ludicrous the idea
that Nixon was a fascist she's again
she's talking like the 60s this was the
the moment in the 60s when you had the
rise of youth culture you had a
capitalist system that was so wildly
successful that it gave teenagers
spending power and power for the first
time in all of human history and it went
downhill from there if you'd like more
sane takes on our insane World check out
our direct message clips playlist and if
you want to watch more full episodes of
our live round tables watch our round
tables playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell